foreign
[Music]
back to the dating app for you buddy
so I don't want to not leave my options
open I guess
oh oh
she was really connecting with Xavier
would you like to see it because if
you're a kid yeah I would literally
throw my whole [__] phone out the
window if he comes back and he takes her
back
it is a sickness
all right so what's your deal I mean
like life-wise currently I work as a
substitute teacher
I do cosplay
this is ridiculous okay uh I am a
teacher at Franklin and I yeah I love
going to Comic-Con interesting really oh
my God
Xavier he has an irrational fear of
urinals
it's not a rational
every time I use urinal I think like
other dudes dick steam is still around
you smell it
yeah you can feel the heat you smell it
you can feel the heat there's fumes
and then you're gonna pee in that [__]
and that's just gonna Splash on you well
thank God for the [__] companies that
put that little rubber [__] that little
rubbery thing that been suffering
through all the piss like imagine being
reincarnated into one of them rubbery
things hey man that gotta be one of the
worst experiences because not only are
you immortal which is a gift but you're
morally gonna be getting beat on to be
discorded in the trash one day once you
accumulate too much pee that got to be
the worst era isekai ever the the the
plastic thing is it's not for for the
smell I thought it was to absorb the
impact so don't Splish Splash everywhere
I think it's full I think it's for the
smell I think it's for the impact it
could be both but I'm confident because
I noticed when it doesn't when you when
you hit the glasses but when it got the
when it got the when it got the rubbery
thing it breaks the impact
screens used in urinal helps prevent
drain blockage as well as provide Odor
Control has nothing to do with split
splashy I don't even know what the word
is for Splish Splash I keep saying split
Splash like it's a term I can't even
Google it Google it it's right there I
got it right here bro why you got to
look for it yo Google you're Google
better than mama how about Swiss Splash
you don't have the right word you gotta
put in the right word can't put Splish
Splash what's the word yeah do split
splash
what's the word though Splash that's a
splash answered
anti-splash prevent foreign objects from
falling into the urinal cause blockage
preventing liquids from Splash that can
keep hygiene yes it stops I swear to God
it stops you know what that's not the
first you you went looking until you
found it about this item I was just
looking at the different things it does
it definitely does okay you know what on
one item okay
I found your answers
you find the item you found a b item on
on uh Amazon that does that come on now
B that's not how you conduct the
research [__] well you think yours
conduct research no you didn't ask
Google just [__] ask Google hold up
hold up put in anti-splash urinal screen
anti-splash yeah because that never mind
well go ahead go say because that's what
that's that [__] does you do and you're
the same one you looked up it's the same
one you looked up go pull it up pull it
up
it definitely stopped the Splish Splash
you see he getting mad over
peace anti-splash urinal screens because
that's what you entered hold up but
that's what I'm saying they do they stop
the splash I know because
don't try to guess like me about my
experience
yes
[__] getting Battlefield 100
they stop these anti-splash urinal
screens and I know this because one of
them hold on you know what it is one of
the most annoying things about using
urinals especially when they got a
little bit
it's annoying when I'm peeing and I'm
getting my pee back I'd ask for it back
it's like giving a gift and then
receiving crumbs back it's like no I
just gave you the cake why are you
throwing crumbs at me [__] are
gonna call us peace Flash and preach
[Music]
no I'm right about this one it
definitely it definitely does stop this
way why are you getting excited over a
peace plan because you can't lie to me
yes and then you want a girl boss
afterwards you what what Gaslight girl
boss girl boss what does this guy girl
boss has to do I don't know what that
means tell me what the [__] that means
you never heard of Gaslight Grill bars
gatekeep no peace blast I haven't okay
that's three things right huh what okay
do you know what those means Gaslight I
know what the [__] is girl boss what
about gatekeeping you know gatekeeping
is yes I understand they do that too
because you used to be a bouncer
okay let's carry on what's girl buzz you
still haven't answered my question hey
preach hey preach the quintessential
girl boss like you've been girl boss
hasn't he we'll have to I'll let you
look it up later
I don't even know what the [__] that is
[__] that [__] nah [__] well if you
want to Google yourself
okay there peace Flash
yes
girl boss is a community of ambitious
women who are finding success on their
terms uh there's no terms look at you
with your little own YouTube channel
killing it you're doing the same thing
you're the girl so I can't be a girl
boss only you can every time we say go
bad [__] you go like this that's you
[__] that's me trying to channel my
internet you a bad [__] you a bad [__]
and a b flash thank you thank you
thank you
ranking video and you're like no you're
such a bad [__] never doubt yourself I
feel like it's okay there's nothing
wrong with it you're the one that said
that and still be a masculine man and be
a girl
you could identify as what you want you
sliding and you're gatekeeping and you
grow boxing as far as I can't remember
perfume has always been something like a
part of my life it's a big part of my
life because it it can complement your
attire and what you're wearing and
that's part of your you know identity a
couple of months back remember I
received a package from Samberg I was
able to test for a month doji and
Gabbana program and I bought this and as
you can see it's it's almost over yeah
that's how much I used it I'm about to
re-up on that but I always like to have
a couple of perfumes on hand you know
because I like to switch the perfumes
depending on what I wear you know now
what we have here is three wonderful
perfume that I'm gonna try grooming
Lounge uh handsome devil but madurai
I'll try them and if I like them I'll
use them for a month and buy the real
thing it smells very light
and fruity not fruity or just you know
hints of fruits you know what I mean
monthly subscription is only 17 and you
get a 30-day Supply what's more you get
to choose any of the fragrances you want
each month so there are no surprises
it's available in Canada and United
States so click on the link below right
now and save 55 off
you're the same Bird yeah
get it absolutely you just like fall
into the urinal I don't know germaphobe
kind of a thing no it's just like you
get pushed into a urinal so your day is
just ruined
do you have good hygiene
I put a beard conditioner on today that
counts that counts it's hygiene
important
yes I have a very sensitive sense of
smell but let's put this to the test
do I have to
the way he was
what I thought he's gonna grab her head
like how my dick she's
crazy he smells nice
I think you two are really cute together
thank you I appreciate that are you down
for one dollar margaritas
are you unsure
[Music]
I'm sorry back to the dating app for you
buddy
no I get it no like that was it I
thought that was a good that was a good
yeah but I'd be interested in talking
more I had a good time though
nice to meet you Celeste
how you feeling you like down I feel
really bad because like I did like him a
lot but also I don't want to not leave
my options open I guess yeah it's all
good man it's like the rest of your uh
life carry on
hey she said listen
uh he was cool
I think I could do better
see for Grandma so
see him I would like to keep him around
so I could just observe I still think I
could get better on the market because
if he was a giga Chad she would have
been like let me let me let me let me
grab my chips and little home because
I'm getting a million bucks but she
don't see him that way no she'll be like
yo you can sniff you can sniff all you
want I'll sniff too yup [__] nice to
meet him Daniel I'm so
those have been going for you so
Daniel's red flags are people who can't
take a joke tell her a joke
this guy looks like he codes while doing
cocaine that's exactly what he looks
like this guy this guy's got a dirty
sanchez kind of feel and I don't even
think he's Latino it's just something
about him that's nasty what is it the
greasy hair yeah and the smile too and
The Petal glasses
I was gonna say that Steve Jobs glasses
but that works I said what I said hey I
ain't mad at you
it's like if we're hanging out like
I like to give people [__] sometimes
yeah me too yeah
I get my friends [__] all the time
um
all right let's go why'd you press the
button you're smacking your gum and it
was kind of gross you're right sorry I
forgot to spit it out before I came out
here okay it's okay it was really nice
to meet you
[Music]
listen the only people who get flat tops
like that are people who don't pay taxes
okay there is nothing about joining the
professional forces that allow you to
have a haircut like that I'm 21 21
you I
depends on the maturity level I suppose
all right yeah okay what was your most
uh toxic moment
might be just sometimes I take more than
I give
in terms of a relationship
who'da thought the girl who thought she
could do better is selfish and dating
shocker
oh
sorry it's okay I'll get all good she
was really connecting with Xavier
[Laughter]
oh hell no don't bring this guy up
listen I want you to bring this guy up
and I want this guy to buzz it out
listen you could do what you want I
would literally throw my whole [__]
phone out the window if he comes back
and he takes her back my King's out
there all of you watching I don't care
if you haven't touched [__] or sniffed
it or looked at it your whole goddamn
lives okay if you get rejected by a girl
and then she run through a bunch of and
she tried to come swing back to you and
you take her back I want you to chop off
your [__] dick and never reproduce I
never want to see that [__] on any
screen in my life again just thinking
that that is disgusting Behavior it is a
sickness of the highest order it is
deviant therefore we don't want it huh
this is America
[Music]
he smells nice what did you get rid of
Octavio if you connected I just I just
wanted to see who else was here I guess
because dating is like about
experimenting and meeting multiple
people and not just meeting one person
being done with it would you like to see
Xavier again yeah I'll tell you listen
yo Fresh Prince why are you being third
wheel just get the [__] up off the
screen they told him to say that
hey I don't care how much you pay now
you're saying shots walk off camera and
with how invasive the button is they
didn't have to ask him to say [__]
that's disgusting have some self-respect
young man if you watch her right now
don't ever let nobody cook you like that
then a second day with you I hope so
sounded like happy hour was in
Xavier if he would like to come back of
course of course I'll do that all right
I guess we'll see what he says
oh my God
look who we have here from the grave
it was more fun talking with you than
the other guys appreciate that I do have
to hit the button though yes yes yes you
do yes you do and I'll throw my [__]
phone out the window anyways
after we finish the video
because we have to finish the video for
real
he wants to see his option too and I
ain't mad at him no I think he just has
some self-respect I think he was down to
leave with her at that moment I am mad
at that if if if if if that's what he
says then [__] great to you Xavier he
came down he said I said I'm gonna be
actually I have to press the button
before the things
yeah watch let me see I don't play
Second Chances
[Applause]
let's go last night was up here last
night
[Applause]
is it harder for women to cut off their
[__] that's why I didn't say it for
y'all this is easier for dudes to do
that [__] that's why but ladies if you
could so so up your ovaries and
everything
foreign
now I feel bad